I decided I was going to pray so I
prayed okay and I read the Bible and I
literally prayed and read the Bible I'm
afraid of meeting up with people at a
gay boy yes okay what does the voice of
God sound like find out on this episode
of LED live
[Music]
a closing Darkness welcome to LED live
it's a show where we use the Light of
Christ to expose the darkness found in
media and our culture and today we have
Daniel thank you so much for being on
the show Good to be here today
um Daniel's a social worker you're also
a Christian with just this profound
story of Deliverance or this profound
testimony of Deliverance and so I'm
really excited to to get into it you
know when I first heard your story
um I was I was amazed it reminded me
of a question some people may ask like
you know is God still speaking to his
people today and when I heard your
testimony it was like a resounding yes
he does speak to his people and so I
just want to start from the beginning as
as we jump into this
um if you can share where you're from
and also like your family Dynamic I'd be
glad too
so my story starts
um when I was you know I was born into a
Puerto Rican Family my father's military
we moved around a lot and I was a kid
um and my parents grew up Christian but
when I was up into the age of like eight
or nine they really weren't
um very committed Christians as in going
to church or
um I didn't really see them studying the
Bible or having like family devotions
and stuff it was very just like nominal
Christians and
when I was really little I would see
stuff like I would see like demonic
activity sometimes and yeah and I I knew
that was wrong like I'm like this is I'm
not supposed to be seeing this stuff I
also had like a weird attraction towards
like
um secular music scary movies to be
honest I was just a little too
interested and curious about that sort
of thing and I do believe Looking Back
Now that that was probably just just the
devil putting his influences and trying
to take me away from God's truth and his
love but it's amazing that you're able
to identify that for what it was at that
how old were you when you first started
seeing demonic activity I would say
like seven seven I was like seven and I
remember like there was a we were living
in Georgia at the time and I remember
there was this one night I woke up and I
was really scared I woke up super scared
and I just felt uneasy like this is like
a weird presence and I remember that I
looked at the hall and I saw this little
girl like walking in the hallway and it
was like a ghost figure and
um she had a knife in her hand and she
had like some scar in her neck and she
was like walk she like walked and I just
was so freaked out she's like what in
the world and actually I remember she
like the figure like went into my
sister's room and I still knew of God
and so I was just praying for my sister
and I was really scared
um so like that sort of thing it didn't
happen like every day but I do believe
that because I was being exposed to
different things it was just negative
evil influences okay so you're saying
your parents will work or living out
like nominal Christianity so you have an
understanding of belief of that belief
you had understanding of God when you
saw that activity did you feel
comfortable going and talking to them
about it or you just know Kenny to pray
and everything will be okay I didn't
tell them anything I don't know why my
parents
I mean I would say we had a fairly good
relationship growing up just like any
family things could have been better
um but I didn't think to tell them
anything I just kind of thought it was
just a spiritual thing I I need God
like it is interesting to see that the
differences between God and Satan where
when you have an experience with Satan
it's more of a default to want to hide
it versus with God even when you're so
full of joy and you just want to express
what you felt or experienced with other
people
okay so you're young and you're seeing
this demonic activity and you have an
attraction to secular music and all this
yeah okay so
um did you have any like internal
conflict like between what you believed
versus what you were feeling yeah I did
um so on top of the those external evil
influences
and even God giving me his hope and
peace even in the midst of feeling
afraid
um I still grew up
um knowing the difference between good
and evil like just like major things
like you know good good people don't lie
and they don't steal you know you don't
want to be violent like that sort of
thing it was very general which we can
still find those principles in the Bible
but
um I had a layer of shame because I was
from a young age I don't know five years
old
I knew that I had a same-sex attraction
so I would notice boys more than girls
and I just would fantasize more with the
same gender and
so there was that and I grew up in
knowing that you know the Bible is very
clear about homosexuality and that's not
something that God approves of in terms
of the lifestyle and living out those
inclinations and I felt very guilty
about that I felt very shamed because I
would hear messages at church so like we
would go to church here and there and
um more so after I was like 10 years old
we would go more frequently but I would
hear things in church about like gay
people going to hell that
um not verbatim but messages that those
people were disgusting like othering
them ostracizing them and I didn't like
that attitude and so I just kind of
internalized like wow like I struggle
with this and this I can relate to these
group of people and people are labeling
them and it had me feel like I was those
labels and I was a child so I didn't
know know any better
so yeah I had that internal struggle
wow yeah it sometimes it is a lot more
harm than good when certain situations
are approached in that way or when we
put certain sins on a pedestal
as compared to others because you know
the product of sin is death right across
the board it isn't just this group of
people have this and then the rest of us
are fine and then there's also this um
uh reaction of people tend to sweep
things under the rug or suppress It or
Not address it out of fear or shame or
what have you wow okay so you're around
10 feeling this shame but what pushed
you into into the lifestyle instead of
um I guess continuing to suppress it
sure
yeah so
um that's a great question I like to go
back just a little bit because there was
something that happens that I think
complicated things a little bit more
because it's just like an extra layer
that I had to deal with so when I was
eight years old there was a family
friend
um older brother shared pornography with
me and I was very confused and I knew
that what I was watching was not right
and because of that you know I was eight
years old and these days unfortunately
it's common you know I think the that's
the median age of
um adult children being exposed to
pornography I think as young as six
years old these days which is very sad
but developmentally that affected me and
I noticed that from that time on anytime
I would have had physical touch with
people or
um you know I just was externally
open a little promiscuous like not
touching people and stuff but more so I
just had just the sexual Vibe and I
didn't know what to do with it because I
was exposed to adult material and so
there was that layer too and I just knew
it was wrong but I didn't know what to
do with it I also didn't tell my parents
um I just kind of kept it to my to
myself
so that you know just want to share that
and
um
back to answer your question so when I
was around 10 years old my parents at
this point in my life we really weren't
going to church we would go here and
there and different things
um but they sent us my sister and I to
Puerto Rico for a summer
and we went and during this time I see
how God was leading my sister and I to
learn more about him so my grandma she's
Christian specifically Seventh-day
Adventist Christian she wasn't always
Seventh-day Adventist Christian
um but at this point in my life she was
taking us to church and I was learning
about God and I remember when I first
went to church I was like I didn't like
it it was different I was just like what
is this it's just kind of like just
foreign to me and then I got used to to
it and I noticed people were kind and
loving and it was just a different
atmosphere that I had known up up until
that point so
the end of the summer came my sister and
I went back to the United States
and I remember thinking on the airplane
I remember just being like wow this is
such a fun trip and wow what about
church though like I wonder how that's
going to be because we don't really do
this back at home and I just remember
just like having a sense of like
security I just sensed God just just
reassuring me like don't worry like I'm
gonna take care of it and I just felt
peace I can't explain it it wasn't an
audible voice it just was like a sense
that it was going to be taken care of
so we got back to the United States and
I noticed my so my parents they were on
the break of divorce they had gotten
separated to be honest about that but my
parents said that they decided to
reconcile and I noticed that there was
peace in the home like when I say there
was peace I didn't know that before
there was like a form of chaos I did not
know that was my normal but when I got
there I noticed that like things just
seemed better like the atmosphere was
just there was peace and that spoke to
me and for me hearing my parents say
that God brought them back together
affirmed that God is a God who
intervenes he's active he's loving he's
good because I saw that he he changed
that very dark vibe that I was
experiencing to something just better
and so those were seeds that were put in
me I believe just reassuring that God is
real he is able to restore and you can
trust in him amen wow you know we talk a
lot about on this show show about the
occult and how people may get into that
unknowingly and also the Avenues left
open that gives Satan access into our
lives and some people think it's like
you know a Ouija board or tarot cards
well sometimes it's the
um the the the anger that's within the
home holding on to resentment or the
separation of parents and all this stuff
like those are Avenues in which Satan's
like oh I have an open door and comes in
and Causes Chaos it is so amazing that
you were able to see the night and day
effect as a young child like wow there's
peace here God is here because of the
the
um restoration of my parents and it just
has a ripple effect doesn't it amen yes
it does I was so surprised and to be
honest with you just to comment about
this I remember as a child
um this is true I wanted them to get a
divorce okay honestly just like tired I
was tired I mean it was not like they
were externally fighting or being mean I
just had a sense I'm a sense type of guy
I keep using that word
I just felt like it just there wasn't
a togetherness and I just was just I was
tired of seeing certain things
um specifically seeing my mom feel down
and sad at times and I just remembered
as being like y'all just need to
separate okay
but seeing how God I mean that was my
little kid idea you know just thinking
like oh this is best for them just to
like snip snip cut cut and like go about
your life but God is he wants to restore
the whole family you know and I'm sure
it took work there's behind the scenes
that things that they had to work
through I mean I don't know what they
had to do but they were willing to
Humble themselves unto God and he
obviously interceded yeah so that was
the pivotal moment in my life okay so
was it all sunshine and Roses after that
no okay it wasn't it was definitely a
good experience though but life still
continued and there were still struggles
within the family Within Myself
specifically the same sex attraction
um so at this point
in my life you know I'm developing I'm
growing as a boy struggling with that
exposure pornography and struggling with
a lot of lust within me I think that was
part of just the exposure and I would go
to masturbation and pornography even at
that end of an age whenever I could as a
way to escape as a way to feel good and
feel better
and
so I was struggling with that I knew
that that was wrong
um
but I didn't feel like I had anyone to
turn to I felt just like a lot of Shame
like I'm like I don't want to disappoint
my parents I don't have any other
healthy adults that I feel like I could
confide in and I just was very isolated
emotionally and oh yeah that's tough
because I'm thinking from maybe the
perspective of the leaders in the church
like obviously we need to address sin
for what it is but you also want to keep
the line of communication open or the
door open for someone to feel
comfortable enough to come and talk or
to express themselves and I could see
how that would be kind of difficult how
to create the balance between the two I
don't know if you have like I would
agree on how that can happen you know
how do you come hard at something like
this is wrong but also hey like we're
human and we struggle with things that's
something maybe that the leadership
should keep in mind as hard as you try
to combat sin also realize that people
are dealing with things and maybe with
combating sin give them practical steps
into how to overcome instead of you know
people defaulting to shame yeah yeah I
think you I think you put it well you
know just having a balance between
addressing like hey God came to save
sinners
everybody wanted to raise their hand and
know that we he came to save us whether
it's an external struggle that we have
whether it's a better attitude
resentment anger stealing lying Whatever
It Is God wants to restore that natural
that natural
um evil Instinct that we have and he
wants to restore us through his holy
spirit but yeah I just didn't feel like
I had anyone there coaching me or
helping me
um part of it I can be honest and say I
didn't speak up you know maybe these
days I think there's a lot of people
just speaking up about raw real issues
um and that's changing now
but also I think there's that layer of
Shame within religious circles like
because we know this isn't right and so
like we just feel ashamed that we're
struggling with this thing and we
shouldn't be doing it so I think there's
we have to just is what I think we just
have to work through those things our
own selves and with God's help be open
enough to help and help other people
engage in the right resources and the
right connections because nobody's
perfect but we are on an upward
trajectory as Christians like God wants
to restore us and he wants to sanctify
us and that that takes time and effort
absolutely
um okay but yeah so at this point like
you don't feel comfortable
um no talking to either Church
leadership or your parents so you
growing up becoming a man but you're
still having these struggles talk to me
about what college was like sure so yeah
I had all those struggles up until
Elementary Middle School you know I
being isolated
so I went to college I
think we're to start I was really
focused in academics very focused at the
same time I took the opportunity I think
like many college students to explore
right and see like what are my values
specifically for me an ongoing struggle
for me was how do I reconcile the same
sex attraction versus being a true
Christian who is biblical you know who
follows God's principles yeah that's a
good question and I just was I just had
this internal dichotomy like how can
these two things coexist God like help
me I didn't say this but growing up I
did try to pray the gay way all the time
like I'm like Lord please take this away
please take this away I would try to
even ask God to help me like have dreams
with girls and but anything yeah
anything but this you know is what how I
was seeing it because of the layer of
Shame
but I was in college and exploring
myself and I kind of got sucked into the
gay culture yeah if you can share the
moment where
um that pushed you into Community or
yeah the the
lgbtq community that was on campus can
you do you remember you know yeah yeah I
got you yeah so I was
um at the University and for those who
don't know I went I went to a Christian
University and so I went and the first
day literally the first day I was there
I went to the cafeteria I was having
lunch with some friends and I heard this
guy in the cafeteria scream a gay slur
and it was directed towards me and I
remember being like really off put by
that and it was just like okay and I
didn't know what to do I didn't want to
make a Ruckus through I just made new
friends
I wasn't gonna I'm gonna keep the peace
so I was telling a friend about it who
had gone to the university and he was
like oh that's not right you need to get
connected to this specific group which
was an lgbtq plus affirming group that
was not officially a group of the
campuses but it was a group of students
from that University that got together
outside of the University campus and so
he got me connected to them and it was
the first time that I met other lgbtq
people in person and
I felt affirmed it was a space where
that I needed to be for a time but in
that space there were a lot of
conflicting things that I saw that were
not biblical like they would affirm the
lgbtq plus lifestyle people would drink
people were open about smoking and I'm
just like these aren't things that I
feel like are okay and also is
detrimental to me and to other people
and I don't that's not really what I'm
looking for but I still explored it
and so I guess because it was like a
sort of exchange you're looking for
community and if this is what comes with
the community then all right yeah yeah
exactly and I honestly I wanted Godly
friend I wanted good Godly Christian
friends but because I felt ashamed with
the same sex attraction I kept myself
far away from them because you know in
church I heard a lot of hate towards
that community
and one thing about me was and it still
is I want to be authentic I don't want
to be someone else for someone's else
for someone else's comfort you know and
so I I just kind of struggled with like
the church and the opportunities to be
connected with you know on-campus
Ministries I'm sure that there were good
people in them I just didn't explore
that route so anyways that's how I got
sucked into the gay culture I was
eventually introduced to you know
marijuana for the first time drinking
and I'm not saying that all lgbtq people
do this but this was just my experience
and I just kind of easily adopted that
lifestyle of drinking and smoking here
and there and I eventually started going
to the club and going out to party this
is with also you know not just my lgbtq
plus friends but other friends of mine
and I just kind of had a um God took it
back back he was in the back burner in
my life at that time okay so I want to
um kind of go forward into when you got
into a relationship and how out of that
came the pivotal moment in your life can
you share a little bit about that yeah
so I was focused in my academics
everything else was in shambles I mean
my emotional life my emotional life like
I was seeing a counselor like crying my
guts out
um talking about the traumas I had
experienced the internalized homophobia
that I had the internalized racism that
I had it's a lot of layers of just shame
and unworthiness and
I just was really going through it on a
personal level but academically I was
excelling and just like focused on
getting my degree to be honest and I hit
a Crossroads where there was this guy on
campus and I would see him every so
often and I I honestly always had an
interest in this guy and I had a feeling
he was like one of us you know lgbtq
people and at the time that's how I was
thinking and so I saw him and anyway one
thing led to another
um I spoke I spoke to him
um and we started talking and then we
eventually started dating and we became
official partners and he had everything
that I wanted in a man like he was
attractive he was smart he was hard
working likable like to be honest with
you I'm not coming from a prideful place
I'm just stating like facts like people
would say that we were like a power
couple you know like so we had a lot of
like a good reputation with those around
us and we had a pretty good relationship
but what
I still was struggling because I'm like
this is not biblical and I wow so that's
like a nagging yes okay it was in the
back of my mind like this isn't
what's in scripture because remember I
was still in college and exploring how
to reconcile my sexuality and the
biblical beliefs I know to be true yeah
but something is keeping you there like
something's keeping you in the community
something's keeping you using drugs or
continuing um being addicted to
pornography like could you identify what
it is you're searching for that is
making you so willing to put up with
everything else
I appreciate the question yeah seriously
honestly the root of why I was doing all
those things
um was emotional intimacy so the reason
why I was doing all these things
um and I let my parents did many things
well but one of the things that I felt
was lacking since I was a child or when
I starting when I was a child was that
emotional bond with my parents and I
believe it's not like their fault
because I had that shame I would
distance myself myself from them so I do
have responsibility to to take their
um and because of that I found that oh
these these things are filling my lack
you know in very artificial ways you
know I drink or I'd smoke and oh I'm in
a new world I'm feeling like wow this is
fun for it for a time you know I was
hooking up with other guys before I met
my boyfriend and you know it wasn't
fulfilling but it was invigorating for a
time you know it was like oh like I was
just kind of exploring this other route
so to speak and um that's just kind of I
think for me was that emotional intimacy
is what I was craving so I met met a guy
he was my boyfriend and so I was getting
that with him
he's kind of all these things that
really weren't fulfilling me because at
the end of the day I would still hear
God tell me like Daniel this is not this
is not my plan for you okay so you're in
this lifestyle but you're still hearing
the voice of God saying hey something
isn't right here yeah wow um just active
Pursuit he is he's always pursuing after
us even though we want to listen to the
voice of Shame even though we want to
look at all the things we're doing wrong
I I see him just turning my head Dana
look to me I got you hey you have you
have your back towards back towards turn
you know what is it you're back towards
me you know he's just patiently waiting
on me to acknowledge Him and to converse
with him and I got to the point where
these convictions were very strong like
honestly there's this one time I was at
the club with my partner and I'm dancing
and like to be honest with you
I was the life of the party like I would
go there and like I just know how to be
an influence
yeah yeah okay and but it was for evil
and I would and I would just get a sense
that this is not I'm not using this
properly and I would hear God this one
time I heard him say like Daniel who are
you right now wow and I felt like he was
questioning me because he knew I was out
of character he was like you're not
being who you think you are I was being
who I thought I was supposed to be you
know a gay male you know like a bush
Queen you know um the life of the party
for the wrong reasons and I was just
adopting an identity around the same sex
attraction that I hadn't explored before
okay I started to hear God's voice more
and so I would go to the Bible and pray
I I didn't care if I was in sin I'm like
I keep on hearing you God so therefore
I'm gonna try to keep the that
um portal open for communication you
know keep God open in my life in terms
of reading the Bible and looking to him
in prayer and so I was doing that and I
was experiencing God's love in very rich
ways I was um reading the book of Psalms
and so the book of Psalms is a book
where people are so open to God they're
expressing their heart they're crying
out to him they're rejoicing to him and
I felt like God was really addressing in
that book like hey like you want
emotional intimacy here you go all my
people are able to do this they're able
to be real with me and I was just seeing
a picture of God that I needed that I
hadn't really seen was okay I always
felt like as a boy specifically like
being emotional was frowned upon you
know you can't express yourself too much
and you have to be a certain way and so
I just kind of was like all right then
so I would suppress this part of me that
was very much I God created me that way
and he was affirming me like hey I this
is what you need me and I want you to be
yourself and he was doing that through
the book of Psalms and I was growing to
just really love him and I would to be
honest with you there were there would
be nights where sometimes my boyfriend
would sleep in the same bed as me and I
would be reading out loud and we'd just
talk about God I know that sounds like
maybe a little contradictory but it was
the that's true it happened
but there was a Crossroads and yes there
was this Crossroad started when my
boyfriend's brother came to visit and
whenever he came
I was cooking and I remember him and I
were talking and just talking about life
and he was telling me that he had some
struggles and he was he's going through
some things and I remember giving him
Godly counsel and I felt grieved and I
felt like the Holy Spirit I grieved the
Holy Spirit and I just had the sense
that God was like Daniel you're speaking
to people and giving them Godly advice
but you're not actually living in my
True Light fully and if you're not a
instrument for me then you're going to
be an instrument for Satan if you're not
fully committed to me and I felt
lovingly but directly rebuked and I was
so saddened that I that I was doing that
and I literally after that conversation
with him I went straight to my I excused
myself to go to my room I got on my
knees and I started crying to God
because I felt so I felt so sad that I
was cheating on him I was learning of
him but then here I was living a double
life and I remember
that I prayed and I was like Lord I'm so
sorry for what I have been doing please
forgive me help me to please change
change my situation change my my life
help me to come into repentance and then
I remember thinking like you know
I need to get out of this relationship
but I don't know how to get out of this
and I pray the specific prayer and I do
believe it was the Holy Spirit like
impressing upon me to pray this and I
prayed and I asked God Lord I need you
to show me what my life would look like
if I were to stay with the man but when
I said that in the back of my mind I
knew that he was not going to go against
his word and the reason why I prayed
that was because my partner at the time
he was one of these guys where if there
was anything that I did that didn't like
about him or was uncomfortable with he
was so quick to change really he was
very chivalrous but it got to the point
at times where I would feel like I was
an idol to him almost like I describe it
in this way for more people to relate I
would describe it to I would describe it
as like a guy dating a girl who he
really likes and doing anything he wants
anything she wants just to get her you
know buying her flowers but giving her
affection
infection yeah and so I felt like I was
in that situation and so I needed
even though the Bible is clear I needed
a I needed God himself to show me that
hey you're on a trajectory that is going
south you're not following my way and so
I needed him to show me where my life
was headed
so I prayed that prayer and
um he did answer my prayer which I can
get to
if you want me to do that now or yeah
yeah okay so a couple weeks passed I
will say this though like there's this
little joke like be careful what you
pray for be careful what you wish for
because God God's serious if you're like
Lord um you know help me with my
patience he's going to put you in
situations that will help you with your
patience like combative not always
combative but anyway it's just like
combating the pride exactly so I just
think that's so funny on his part really
but yeah you're so right that he's there
he he's he's like as he says in his word
he's knocking at the door of our hearts
and once we just a crack in the door
he's like okay let's do it yeah that's
awesome okay so good share your
experience yeah so oh man Lord he's so
good seriously like yeah
um so a couple weeks past of that after
that prayer and I was at a work trip in
another city
and I get there and I was at the hotel
it was like two-day training and I
wanted to explore the city so I was on a
gay app
um and I wanted to meet other lgbtq plus
people and I met this um respectable
couple on there and it was strictly you
know platonic interaction and I was just
like all right I'm gonna go you know
hang out with them they were at a local
bar so before I go I decided I was going
to pray so I prayed okay and I read the
Bible and I literally prayed and read
the Bible I'm afraid of reading up with
people at a gay boy yes okay
um it wasn't a gay bar it was just a
regular bar but they were they happened
to be gay yeah just to clarify
um and I felt kind of Blasphemous I was
like oh God like I'm not trying to be
Blasphemous Lord but I want you to come
with me I don't know why I just was like
I just I wanted his present I wanted his
protection I wanted his guidance and so
yeah I did that and I did laugh
internally like wow I hope I hope I'm
not being too hypocritical and so I just
went in good faith
trying to have a good time and so we get
I get there
and right when I get to the bar I see a
car there and I hear the Holy Spirit say
that is the car of the people that
you're going to meet and I'm like
okay and the car is the same make and
model of the car that my boyfriend was
driving at the time so I felt like that
was a sign that God was giving me like
remember he reminded me of my prayer
like remember the prayer show me what my
life would look like if I were to stay
with the man right or here you go same
vehicle and so before I walk into the
bar and I see the car I know okay God is
answering my prayer this is a Divine
appointment
so I get there I meet them and so the
couple there was one of the partners was
a little older than the younger one
the older one really reminded me of me I
felt like I was seeing myself like 30
years down the line
more like 20. okay something because I
was like 21 at the time I think and he
said he was in his he was like 47 so it
was more like 20 something years ahead
and I just felt like we had the same
personality we had the same interests
and we had a lot of commonalities and
then the partner was really like my
partner at the time he was funny
attractive chill like easiest to get
along with
um such a wonderful just like partner
really and they just seem like like down
to earth guys
we were talking and stuff and then I
find out that the younger couple of the
younger partner smoked weed at the time
I spoke okay okay and so I invited
myself to hang out with them and to go
to go smoke honestly so we go and we get
into that car that that the Holy Spirit
told me it was their car and I'm like it
says confirmation right there yeah and
it might sound like really like
conflicting like how was a Christian in
this situation but I'm just sharing you
sharing with you my story you know this
is really what happened and so we get to
their house when I walk in I'm like
because I lived with my boyfriend at the
time and I'm like this feels like my
house I had the same Vibe it had the
same setup I'm like oh my gosh okay and
so we get to the back we start smoking
and they start telling me about their
life and I'm like so tell me about your
life like
just tell me about you guys and they
were telling me that you know
um they were together and um they
started telling me that they had a lot
of money they had like they were
millionaires they had a couple different
like Avenues in which they made money
and I'm like okay that's that's cool and
I was trying to actually ask them
questions on how to make more money and
stuff and I was trying to be practical
and talk with them about those things
and then they tell me you know like we
have an open relationship it wasn't
always like that but we started sleeping
with other people and inviting other
people into the bedroom and it wasn't
the older couple the older partner was
like it wasn't my ideal but it just kind
of happened to get to that and I
remember thinking to myself like oh like
I wouldn't want to do that I don't agree
with that but okay and so then
when that conversation was coming to a
close the younger partner he gets called
into work so because they worked with
computers so the younger couple the
younger partner goes inside and then I'm
talking with the older guy and
he at this point is like so Daniel so
tell me about you and your boyfriend
like what do you like about him and so I
was like yeah I like everything about
him he's attractive he's nice he's hard
working like I really love him and then
the holy spirit is like Daniel I need
you to tell him what you're struggling
with you need to tell him your
conviction and I'm in mind I'm like Lord
right now yeah he's a stranger like I
don't know who he is and I drank a
little bit I smoked a little bit like
I'm like okay
so I'm like yeah and even though I love
him you know I'm just struggling
struggling a little bit because I'm a
bible-believing Christian specifically a
Seventh-Day Adventist Christian and I
believe what the Bible has to say about
homosexuality and I just don't think
it's right okay just laying I laid it I
did okay and he was like oh
um
yeah he's like that's interesting that
you say that because you know when I was
exactly your age I was also seven to
having this Christian and I was also
struggling with whether or not I should
live the lifestyle hmm and I was like oh
wow yeah and he he goes on and he tells
me that he grew up in the slums of
Brazil and Christian Seventh-day
Adventist Christian missionaries came
and he learned about God and he would he
fell in love with Jesus he would carry
his Bible around everywhere and like to
the point where gang members would not
fight him they wouldn't mess with him
because they were like oh no he knows
God so they wouldn't they wouldn't mess
with him and it was a form of protection
and then he said when he turned
um 21
he said that he talked to his pastor and
he told him hey I have same-sex
attraction
what what do I need to do with this and
his Pastor told him you know it's not a
sin to struggle with that inclination
but it is a sin when you live out those
feelings and yeah which is is biblical
and I mean God can't condemn us for
struggling with with a Temptation a
Temptation yeah that's not sin it's
following through with that
and so he said that he was upset at God
he was like I'm just so mad that why
would you allow this God why would you
allow me to have this feeling and not be
able to act it out and so he told me he
decided to choose to live the lifestyle
and then he starts telling me he's like
you know I live a wonderful life you
know it's good to be gay you you you
know
um you have friends in high places being
lgbtq plus gives you special access to
things and he starts telling me and
about his lifestyle and it's very
Earthly and I remember hearing him I'm
like yeah that's one perspective but
there's eternity with Jesus with God
streets of gold right special like
development that we get to have when we
get to heaven that right now we we don't
get to experience in the full essence of
God we get to hang out with the angels
we like that is so much better than this
temporary 80-year life on this Earth
being a millionaire is what I'm thinking
in my head but he's just you know giving
me the list of the reasons why it's a
good thing to be living out the
lifestyle and having a lot of money
and then his partner goes in and I think
that was perfect timing because God was
like all right like we're going to wrap
it up now and he
speaks and I feel like it was the Holy
Spirit speaking through him because I
felt like it was a call to me and he was
like saying you know you know we have
friends who they they don't live the
lifestyle they are living with the
opposite sex they're married and a
heterosexual relationship and you know
they're because they're Christian and
you know we respect them but you know
it's your choice and he says just the
same way that the devil's not going to
grab you by the hand and make you make
bad decisions God's not going to grab
you by the hand and make you make good
decisions and I feel like God was
speaking through him telling me so now
it's your choice Daniel this is your
life this is what your life could be if
you were to stay in the trajectory you
know
it's my choice do I want temporary
worldly
um accolades and money and Prestige or
am I going by going to live by faith
trusting God's word and live for an
eternity
Eternal Bliss peace love joy like
I was already walking with God so it was
my trust in God was already there and I
told God I was going to trust him I'm
like all right God I'm trusting you with
this the next day after the work trip
I was struggling with like how am I
going to break up with my boyfriend I
mean I made it I made up I knew what I
was going to do but I was like how am I
going yeah how is this going to be
implemented and so it was just simple I
just broke up with my boyfriend the next
day I told him exactly what happened
whether you believe me or not
and told him I'm sorry but I have to
choose God
I had to and um and that's a valid
reason yeah it is everything could be
Sunshine roses like great but that is a
valid reason making a decision for
Christ and this isn't in line with him
here's my decision
how did he respond to that or he's like
made you made the decision regardless of
how he responds I'm sticking to my
decision I did
um and I haven't shared this part but I
feel like the audience really should
know about this so even though we broke
up there was a time where
because we were being intimate with each
other physically I do believe that
played a part as to having a bond with
this person and I was
wanting to at times be with him still
because he was my
he was my friend as well he was my
friend was my companion I we did life
together and so I didn't have community
but God
he started putting people in my life to
where I got connected to a prayer group
and we would pray for each other we
would pray for other people and God was
catering to my need he's like I know you
need Community I'm going to provide the
right Community for you meanwhile I was
still struggling with wanting to be with
my partner even though I chose God my
life up into that point was opposed to
God I was living you know away from God
so it took time for me to adapt to learn
what it means to be a true Christian how
to live that out little by little
and it looked
um it looks differently it looks
different for everyone but for me he
taught me how to have Community with
people via prayer he taught me how to be
real with them he then started
convicting me about certain things
little by little
um uh start I think the next point was
um what I wore I used to wear very
flamboyant clothing but only because I
thought that that's who I was yeah
because that's what people told me that
I was and
there was one day I woke up and I just
felt like God just I felt convicted like
okay Daniel like now is the time to
let's get rid of someone's clothes and
she's like okay you know it's a natural
progression yeah it was a natural
progression it was interesting the power
level that's there like how Satan's uh
way is such a counterfeit to Gods
because once you open the door and you
start living in sin it leads to the next
sin and the next sin and the next sin
more shame yes peeling away the the the
layers and walking in righteousness
walking in the way God wants to it would
lead to the next thing to the next thing
making steps towards Perfection amen
yeah exactly and it didn't feel hard it
didn't he wasn't judging me
to be honest thank you God for reminding
me because it wasn't just one day he
told me to take those clothes off he put
a little seat in my mind like oh like I
feel like some of the things that I wear
I'm not really too into and then I would
think like uh I don't like how I'm
portraying this is not really who I am
and then he was he helped me make the
next step of like taking the clothes out
and you know giving it away and that was
another layer and then the other layer
was you know
um
eventually it he got me connected to a
group of people who were studying the
Bible so I learned how to really study
the Bible and go deeply with God and I
learned how to incorporate scripture in
prayer and I would see God's
intervention in people's lives I would
like to share a quick story about that
there was
um I think this was during covet a year
by this point I was really spending
large amounts of time praying the word
of God and praying for people and
I had this sense and that somebody in my
life who was a family member to out of
respect I'd like to keep their you know
identity private but this person I felt
like they weren't Walking with God I
felt like they just were really
Meandering they were stuck and at any
time I would pray I would just hear
their name just their name would pop up
into my mind and I'm like all right I'm
praying for this person and one day I
just prayed and was like God
I need you to give this I didn't say I
need you I said something along the
lines of I pray Lord that you would give
this person a dream and I pray that you
would just give him a dream to show them
where they're headed right now I pray
Lord that you would just just leave them
something along the lines of that and
the next day this person calls me and
they're like
um my family calls me DJ that's my
nickname so they call me and they're
like DJ you would never believe this and
I'm like what yeah like what happened
and they're like I had a dream the
minute they said that the hairs on my
arms stood up and I was just like
what is she what is she gonna say yeah
and she was like I had this dream and
Jesus came a second time and there were
billions he's like billions and billions
of angels that came from this guy she
said it was so many angels there and
she's like
I didn't see you there nor did I see
another one of my family members and she
was like people were being taken up to
heaven and I was still there and she
said that she talked to one of the
Angels she was like is my name in the
books is my name in the books and she
said the angel was like oh well let me
check let me go check and she said that
when they went to go check she woke up
oh and she told me that she really
needed that because she knows that
there's some things in her life that was
not right with God and when she said
that I was praising God and just
thanking him so much for saving other
people like it's not just about me
anymore you know I really just want to
see people experience God's goodness and
this is my family member who I love and
um it's such a it's so humbling to see
God answer prayer like seriously guys do
not sleep on prayer There Is Power
when we go to God in scripture he will
always be faithful to his word we can be
sure of that and he answered my prayer
in that way I've seen God bring people
back to church and
um I don't know what to make of it I
just think that's God's grace like he
wants us to be part of the solution he
wants us to trust in him yeah we have
difficulty yeah we have Character
defects yeah we struggle sometimes but
he promises to give us the victory that
is sure whether it's in 20 years and 10
years in five years that Victory still
stands today it just takes time and I've
seen that in my life that God's been
taking layers away and other layers and
adding righteousness adding more
positive things in my life that is
coherent to his word have I tripped up
yes many times but there's that Bible
verse that talks about you know a
righteous man falls seven times right he
doesn't fall once or twice three times
he falls seven that's God's number but
he gets right back up that's what makes
him righteous yes the wicked stay down
they trip up they fall they feel so
ashamed So Unworthy I might as well just
like continue in it no snap out of it in
the name of Jesus God will help you he
will he loves you so much he died for us
so it took me time to really Embrace
that and that's just been my experience
and no it hasn't been perfect I still
struggle
um with the lust addiction but after I
broke up with my boyfriend
God was addressing all these other
things and then he was like you know I
also want to address this other thing
that's in your heart and I just knew
what he was going to say and now she's
like oh the pornography and he's like
yeah we're gonna know if you didn't see
that part okay I just I just it was it
was such a such a part of my life it was
my normal so I didn't think twice about
that but he was like you know this is
occupying your heart and I want your
entire heart you see how good I am you
see that I love you you see that I'm
blessing you let me take care of you and
so he got me connected to a men's group
um I also to be frank about this this
men's group is a 12-step program so I do
the 12 steps I am connected to that
program and it's been a beautiful
experience to grow and learn to trust
God
um and I still struggle but I have seen
a lot of progress I don't have this
Obsession anymore with pornography
um or an obsession with being
promiscuous do I get triggered sometimes
yes but all humans get triggered whether
you get triggered to get angry triggered
to get sad triggered to eat everybody is
going through something but now you have
the tools to get through that instead of
just falling into it exactly and I have
the right Community now that I can I can
call up a brother and be honest with
them they can listen to me I can listen
to them and God is really getting to the
root of my the addiction which is the
emotional intimacy he wants me to have
intimacy with him he wants me to have
intimacy with other people sometimes
it's one-sided and just hear me out on
this as Christians sometimes God will
bring certain people in our lives where
he wants to cultivate a pure character
in us that represents him so it's going
to be one-sided sometimes so we can pour
into that person but we're not meant to
do it alone he also puts people in our
lives so we can do this growing together
as a community this is how we reach out
to other people but also as a body of
Christ we we feed off each other's
strengths we also help each other in our
weaknesses so I've seen him doing that
in the context of this group
they're um they haven't seen Faith as me
they're Christians and so we can talk
about God in that way and it's just been
such I didn't think I would be at this
place I used to be so fear full of fear
as a child so ashamed and like God is
just like literally moving away the dark
clouds he is he really is and he's doing
he knows what he's doing he knows I can
trust in him it's it's been a good it's
been a good um couple of years and it's
just a daily thing a Daily Commitment to
God and he's just been showing me so
many
truths you know an experience that I
just wow I know I can trust him
I know it's so good there's so much
there I have questions yeah yeah if you
don't mind I'm just gonna go ahead I'm
gonna take a sip of water yeah going
going back to just your experience I'm
thinking
um as Christians sometimes we can become
honestly overwhelmed with our Great
Commission to go into all the world
preaching the gospel and you hear these
questions like you know what about those
people in the Amazon who no one has
reached them yet or you know there's so
many people in the world how can we how
can the Christians reach out to them and
then we're like no but there's God you
know we're we're supposed to be in
relationship in partnership with him and
it's just so incredible how
um God I guess took it upon himself to
reach you like it wasn't some church
member that came and started doing Bible
studies with you or anything like that
God heard your prayer and answered it in
the way that he knew would reach you
specifically or would get your attention
specifically so it's like um yes you
know it's it's a it's an honest feeling
to sometimes feel overwhelmed but you
were just you were so good at um is
expressing how important prayer is
because God can do things that we cannot
yeah and if we would just take the time
to pray and understand that all of this
is bigger than who we are yes God will
work yeah God will do it what he needs
to do amen um but a question I have for
you is maybe someone is watching right
now and they they are at the place of
they made the decision to come out of
either lgbtq lifestyle or maybe to stop
with their porn addiction or drugs what
have you but they're still dealing with
lust or Temptation yeah and they may
feel that God hasn't forgiven them or
they did their part in terms of
um stopping their lifestyle but you know
what about God's part and taking it away
how would you respond to that
I would respond
um to you and just say God says that he
loves you he's going to take care of you
and it's a process any time that you're
struggling to take talk to him surrender
yourself to him anything any moment that
you have that struggle that comes up
will the urge be there probably but he
says in his word submit to God
submit to God as the first step resist
is the second step and what are we
resisting we're resisting the devil in
those Temptations and the devil will
flee from you so there's that practical
piece of literally out loud surrendering
to God submitting yourself to him
because sometimes I struggle with this
too wanting to do things on my own like
oh I need to I just needs a white
knuckle it I just need to resist I just
need to be stronger I can't do that on
my own it's it's God's power alone
that's able to help and that's his grace
to us so there's that practical piece
and then also if you're struggling with
feeling like you're forgiven you will
struggle the rest of your life it's not
about feeling I'm not trying to sound
harsh for those of us myself included
that are a bit more sensitive it's
really hard sometimes to look past the
feeling and God has worked on me with
that and he's still working on me with
that
um but I've seen progress and just by
faith no
that he has forgiven you know that he's
died on the cross for everyone's sins
including the ones that will never
accept his invitation
and he technically has overpaid but it's
our choice to trust in him
and it takes time what do we do when
we're learning about you know when I'm
learning about you I'm learning about
anyone else we spend time with them so
talk to God it doesn't matter what
you're doing if you're in the car talk
to God if you're washing dishes talk to
God open up your Bible those are two
practical steps that you can take and
trust that God is there with you because
he'll take care of you he'll address
whatever it needs to be addressed I
can't tell you specifically what that
looks like for you but he can he's done
that for me and I know he'll do that for
you amen
amazing thank you so much for sharing
and and listening to your story and in
answering the question you know does
does God still speak to his people today
I'm reminded of the story of Elijah when
he's in the cave and it's just a
reminder that
um amidst the chaos that's happening in
the world today amidst our the
Temptation the personal temptations that
we may face or even the lies that we
might believe about ourselves and our
identity which is different to What God
Says About Us how he speaks to us
despite all of that we can hear his
still Small Voice his loving still small
voice calling after us actively pursuing
us and calling us towards him Amen to
fill those holes those gaping holes in
our hearts you know he can he can
satisfy in a way that nothing else can
thank you so much Daniel for sharing and
being vulnerable and open with us and is
there anything that you'd like to close
with or anything that comes to mind that
you'd like to share as we rub up here
sure if we can pray I would love to pray
us out okay sure all right let's do it
let's bar our heads
dear heavenly father thank you so much
Lord for the opportunity to glorify your
name and to testify that you are
merciful and you are so full of justice
and you want to restore what the devil
wants to destroy I thank you so much
because you see the value in US and
dying on the cross for us I thank you so
much Lord because you are trustworthy
thank you so much because you are
personable and you are truly a friend
Lord I just want to ask for forgiveness
on behalf of anyone listening including
myself and my sister here that you
forgive us for any of our sins that have
put us apart from you whether it be
Character defects or external struggles
that we struggle with I just ask God
that your blood would cleanse us there
is power in your blood and that was able
to defeat the the devil and I just thank
you Jesus because you have the keys to
give us life and I just pray that anyone
that's listening right now
that they would sense your presence I
pray that your Holy Spirit would fill
them that you would bring people in
their lives that can Empower them to
point them to you Jesus that you would
give them practical steps that they need
tailored to their individuality so they
can know that you are walking by them
and that they would get out of this
sinful tendency that we all at times
lean towards I thank you so much because
you promised to change us you promise to
transform us and that is in your power
but you won't do it without our consent
and I thank you for being a gentleman I
ask God that you give us a willingness
to surrender Our Lives to you and I pray
Lord that if there's any distractions in
our lives that are keeping us from
experiencing you that you would convict
us and help us Lord to give you our full
attention I thank you so much for
meeting us exactly where we are thank
you so much for answering prayer I pray
this in the name of Jesus amen amen amen
thank you if you were blessed by this
testimony please leave a like or
subscribe if you would like to see even
more of a little light Studios content
and share this with a friend that you
know or may be blessed by by this story
and many others if you'd like to support
this channel Little Light Studios you
can do so through donating through
patreon or through our website
littlelightstudios.tv or if you would
like a more tangible exchange exchange
we have a t-shirt company called
lightwear you can find those products
and more at lightwear dot shop again
thank you so much for joining and we'll
see you next week on LED live bye
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you